allerdings wieder eure mal ihr habt den
titel gelesen und dachte ich
wahrscheinlich noch so ein deutschland
youtube deutschland video und dann habt
ihr drauf geklickt an uns doch am ende
jede meinung dazu interessiert also
trommelwirbel drittel tut jetzt kommt
meine meinung zu dieser ganzen sache ja
wer denkt dass die training seite
youtube deutschland verkörpert der held
auch mcdonald's führen aushängeschild
von guten burger unser geliebtes youtube
dieser schulhof gehörte bis vor kurzem
noch zu der realschule und dem gymnasium
na ja und jetzt haben sie halt die
hauptschule dazu geholt das heißt wir
sind jetzt eine große gesamtschule und
das ist doch gar nicht schlecht also ich
mag das konzept von gesamtschule jeder
ist unter einem dach und keiner wird
besonders behandelt
außer die kevins die wenn immer
nach dem ganzen product placement werde
jetzt gefunden hat was ohne frage der
zeit bis leute wie merck matan und katja
kraus abitur merken was man auf dieser
ehemaligen nerd spielwiese eigentlich
verlieben können aber wir können es
nicht einfach hinstellen und sagen man
früher war youtube nicht so sie denn sie
funktioniert halt einfach viel zu gut
als dass uns das nicht auch mal erreicht
hätte ich meine soldaten sagen die sind
so gut machen supercoole informative
dokus jetzt also ohne witz wie machen
wirklich wirklich gute dokus die sind
wirklich gut und super informativ und
selbst prosieben gibt sich manchmal auch
bis hin und dann kommt da eine serie wie
berlin tag & nacht um die ecke und
wäscht sie alle weg durch konversationen
wie ich war du hast und ich liebe ihn so
sehr aber leider ist das mein bruder
sind nun treiben sich seit fünf jahren
auf den bildschirm und alle fans die
quoten stehen gut obwohl ich mir sicher
ich habe gerüchte gegeben dass es
vielleicht abgesetzt wird aber konnte
keine quelle finden irgendwie sie
quellen also alt also 2012 schon mal und
so naja egal
dazu noch eine geschichte aus meinem
leben vor ein paar tagen sah sich auf
der bank und hat auf jemanden gewartet
mitten in berlin
und dann ist mir der berlin tag & nacht
drehe fast neben mir aufgefallen und
dazu natürlich auch die passenden fans
wieder begeistert zugeschaut haben dann
passierte etwas was so schlimm war dass
ich es kaum glauben konnte kaum glauben
konnte glauben können
er liefert sich ein erwachsener mann zum
drehen einen super tempo und meine
katzen nervt mich schon den ganzen tag
dahinter ein dreijähriger der tarif und
dann dachte ich so okay vielleicht ist
das und vision mitarbeiter der jetzt
dauerkarte abgeben muss und keine ahnung
wichtig sein
es war ein fan und der sohn gleich
dahinter her so ganz klein klein
armes armes deutschland
da sagst du was worauf ich eigentlich
hinaus wollte müll gibt es überall ml
ist einfach einfach zu produzieren
einfach zu konsumieren und super einfach
zu verurteilen denn ja auch nicht alles
schauen sich diesen müll an nicht weil
es ihnen gefällt weil wir diese
sensations- geilheit in uns haben und
menschen sehen wollen die dümmer sind
als wir damit wir uns besser fühlen und
um das schiff wieder auf richtigen kurs
zu bringen meine landratten zeige ich
euch jetzt mein youtube deutschland
beziehungsweise was ich unter youtube
deutschland verstehe er schafft es über
fleischkonsum zu reden und trotzdem noch
ein richtig lustiges video draus zu
machen
im flur durch ihn schalten viel mehr
leute wieder den kopf ein und denken
darüber nach was sie hören und sehen
anstatt es einfach nur zu kommen zu mir
ich ziehe meinen hut vor dir
weil ich dann da viel besser reinkommen
kann the change mit einer der wohl
kreativsten youtuber in deutschland
natürlich auch kari also kultur die als
kind von in einen topf von lachgas
gefallen sein muss mit matan der absolut
nicht zu dieser liste gehört und alle
mädels machen nur beauty von wegen kelly
und mirella ja ich weiß es sind meine
freunde aber sie sind das beste beispiel
dafür dass mädels lustig sind
walking like you tube zu dicht gefolgt
sind die beiden von vegas films sie
macht schon länger videos als wir alle
anderen zusammen und ist trotzdem immer
noch so mama fucking tour geblieben
ja auch prime macht guten stoff auch
wenn ich es manchmal etwas ab ich finde
versteht ihr affig leute gibt denen eine
bühne die es verdienen und nicht die mit
dvd pack gibt denen eine bühne die es
verdienen und nicht denen die es mit
taschenspielertricks versucht der rote
kreis wird bitte wieder in zukunft
freundlich ignoriert und tipps am netz
werden nur geklickt wenn sie von flo
kommen denn das bei seiner erfindung bis
bald schaut euch meinen lidschatten an
er ist so und fliegt danke coco von
cosmo für das neue paket und reden
klatsche des lebens